foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
happy Saturday we are doing it yet again
we are on the live stream creating art
for the moving meditations 3D challenge
this is stream number two today we got
two more streams after this we are
officially halfway through the challenge
and it isn't too late to start creating
some art you can create something in a
week if you want you can create
something in a day
um so if you guys want to participate in
the internet's largest 3D challenge then
it is certainly not too late there's a
link in the description to download the
files join the Discord and get started
you also might notice
for those of you uh who are working on
your art for those of you who are
somehow done with your art already I
like to use as much time as I possibly
can but there is a submission link it's
in the description
um you're gonna go through it make sure
you are submitting your final piece you
can only submit one time only once so
don't mess it up make sure that you work
on your art for as long as you need to
it's not too you don't have to submit
immediately all right
um
but y'all thank you for joining us uh
today it's gonna be a good time I'm
going to be continuing my art in Unreal
Engine I'm gonna show you kind of where
we left off last week and
um what I did throughout the week
working on the character stuff the
character stuff is the hardest part of
this for me personally
um but we're going to continue working
on the environment and really refining
the environment and getting it to a
point where we feel is really nice
um so that that that's what we're doing
on today's
live stream now we got a couple
announcements
and I'm gonna kick it off
uh with
our very very very special sponsor first
and foremost so I'll see you all in
about a minute and a half and then I got
some more exciting news for y'all before
we hop into the art so stick around see
you soon
something huge happened on my channel a
couple weeks ago I crossed the threshold
that I could only dream of when I
started my channel back in 2006. I am
proud to announce that we have finally
made it to the big time because a raid
Shadow Legends is finally the sponsor of
a Punisher video and if you have never
heard of raid Shadow Legends then let me
pull you out from under that rock and
fill you in raid Shadow Legends is a
free to play turn-based Fantasy game
available on Android iOS and PC the game
is packed with tons of challenging
bosses to fight and literally hundreds
of Epic Heroes to play as including my
favorite hero psycho who is literally my
good buddy D from node seriously they
scanned his face Mo capped his sweet
sweet moves and transformed my good
friend D into a sick beefy Undead
Samurai person and this month raid has a
Non-Stop schedule of special events and
activities including Forge path season
three with a bunch of cool things to
offer including this limited edition
artifact set also raid is cranking out
the skins for a bunch of Champions
including Madame Saras herself and I
swear I do not want to hear a single
complaint after this because death
knight is finally getting the legendary
champion upgrade he deserves so go play
as my good buddy d by clicking that link
in the description below and once you're
in game you'll receive 30 buckaroos
worth of unique bonuses we're talking a
free epic Champion Burgess 200k silver
and energy refill 1xp boost and an
ancient Shard so get on it and happy
Hunting y'all
we made it y'all we made it made it the
big time got that raid Shadow Legends
sponsor I feel good about it you know I
feel good
um so a couple more things that I want
to fill you all in on
um as you know Wacom is one of our
sponsors for the moving meditations
3D challenge I mean I'm using their
tablets all the time you guys know I
talk that's what this is you're all like
do you have some carpal tunnel situation
no this is just so my hand can glide
across this tablet
smoothly that's what this little glove
is
um technically called a hand or pants is
what this thing is called very strange
but Wacom has uh they got a sale going
on right now from the 7th to the 22nd
um there's a link in the description if
you want to go and it's on the intos
tablets specifically
um they're they're chopping off some
dollars for y'all if you're if you're
thinking of picking one up now would be
the time also
also also also I mentioned these kit
bash codes y'all
um and they get sweeter and sweeter
every time so
the first 50 people this code is live
for the first 50 people
um and I believe the code is get hyped
40 get hyped 40 Soto's gonna pin it up
in the live feed right here if you go to
kipash3d.com there's a link in the
description you can go there pull
whatever you want you get 40 off
anything at checkout all right
first 50 people to use that code
and then it's gone it's gone forever
um and kit bash as you know is one of
the sponsors of the movie meditation 3D
Challenge and they have awarded
the top 100 artists
um along with the top five but everyone
in the top 100 Montage gets a kickback
kit bash kit of their choice which is
absurd it's the first time we've ever
had a top 100 prize so thank you to Kip
bash
um anything else anything else oh
finally before we hop into the art every
Monday on the Discord server uh we have
these like these Town Hall meetings I
like to call them and basically we get
together and for about an hour in the
morning we look at your art we have you
come up onto the stage and talk about
your art and we ask you questions
um like how you got your idea what
roadblocks you're running into and we
just have a group conversation super
chill and that's every single Monday so
that'll be this upcoming Monday on the
Discord server Link in the description
but y'all I think that is it
we have officially gotten all the
announcements out of the way it's good
to see everyone here in the chat thanks
for hanging out with us thanks for
joining us
um and it's time to hop in to the art
shall we so let me show you what
let me show you where we left off last
week first and foremost
all right so we're here in Unreal Engine
right
um and let me open up my sequencer let's
open up this appropriate sequence
and hop in here this is our scene
all right we created this last week live
on the Stream
um it's like a little Warehouse
situation and we have this like VR
uh screen display set up here in the
middle of this warehouse and we're gonna
go into detail on this and just keep
fleshing this out
today on the stream that's what most of
our time will be spent is continuing the
environment
um but you're like Clint well what the
heck have you done in the meantime
um
and I've been working on characters so I
realized that Daz studio is free I had
no idea
um and character art and characters in
general when it comes to 3D art is my
biggest weakness
I find it not fun because it's just
troubleshooting 24 7.
um it's quite a hassle for me to be
honest with you and it is the hardest
part it's going to be the hardest part
of this challenge for me I think it's
gonna be a hard part for you as well
but I was figuring out character I
really this week I spent on the
character as you can see so I got this
old man here
um he's going to have a VR headset on
with like wires coming from it maybe
some gauntlets of some sort maybe some
like little uh
little not probes is the wrong word but
like
um
you know those little like medical
things that you put on and they have
wires coming off yeah it'll have he'll
have a bunch of those
um and this is free right so I built
this character out you can you know
select different parts of the character
and give them different
you know different facial features and
do all these different sliders and it's
actually
pretty cool
right so there's a lot you can do
with this program
it's pretty sweet
um and the pants you know like it comes
with a bunch of different uh different
pieces of clothing too that you can pop
on and you take that
and do not judge okay do not judge
because I was running a test you bring
that into c4d okay and you simulate some
pants I'm not going to go any further
than that I don't want this uh
this video to get flagged and pulled
down
um so I got the character essentially
hooked up to the mocap data in c4d and
was able to successfully bind the body
to the mocap data right and I used this
little bind option which is grayed out
at the moment because it's already bound
it's probably because I'm not I don't
have geometry selected
right
and I went through some custom settings
it was specifically setting the mode to
volumetric and checking the use bone
glow and ignore inner polygons box that
really made it work that it had it bind
correctly
um and there's this bone right here this
like root bone this one here and it was
grabbing this
and it was making the growing all weird
and the weights were all off and yeah I
just had to select everything except
that bone and then it worked perfectly
um and then I cranked these arms up here
just so I can get them out of the way so
they weren't interfering with this cloth
Sim
that has been a I wouldn't call it a
failure but I still have work to do on
this cloth Sim it's going to be tricky
so that's the character side of things
that's what I was working on this week
and I will pause the character stuff for
now because
I'm not going to submit y'all to four
hours of just troubleshooting and me
watching tutorials
so we're going to be uh
in Unreal Engine building out our
environment continuing to build out this
atmosphere and as usual you guys know
that I put out these art breakdowns that
are about 20 minutes ish long right
and I'm gonna include all the character
stuff in that art breakdown
um
I'm also on the Discord server too we
kind of talk about the stuff in those
Town Hall Monday Monday little group
chats we can go over some character
stuff as well and figure out what y'all
are having trouble with but that's where
I've been
over the week it's been difficult trying
to run this challenge trying to run the
channel
um and work on this art at the same time
I feel like I only got
two days on this art throughout the week
but hey I know you all have full-time
jobs as well
maybe some of you are in school I think
school's out is probably going to be
going back in pretty soon
so I got no excuses
um
Where Do We Begin oh my goodness so we
have this environment and there's a lot
of details that need to be done like we
built out these tube lights we can
probably attach them to the ceiling
um we built out this like Truss
I think that's the right word and we're
going to I'm gonna probably throw some
monitors like all each one of these
little squares is a monitor so I want to
build out some sort of like
uh Mount system
so all these monitors can be mounted
properly
um but I want to work from as large to
as little as possible so I think the
next like
biggest thing that this needs maybe a
little bit more roof detail I know we
spent some time on the roof we I like
where the lighting is at right now I'll
probably have another version of the
lighting as we
continue to build out our scene but I'm
not going to spend too much more time on
the lighting itself
I'm just thinking out loud at this point
I'm probably gonna stretch out these
columns a little bit more
um maybe we could make the roof a bit
taller perhaps
and I'll pull up my pure ref document
which has all my references and I can
actually look at uh
all these references here so to figure
out how tall this roof should be you
know and maybe
it's as tall as it needs to be
maybe we can run these lights
down the length of this Warehouse as
opposed to
um
left to right we can go front to back
with the lights
an example front to back with the lights
we can probably put some piping I think
that's probably what I'll do is I'll add
some piping on the stream today
um I don't know how much we'll get into
decals and grunge but that's going to be
a thing still
um well Ian Hubert reference here
lots of good detail like the roof is
really what makes this
or the ceiling rather is really what
makes this
so good so good oh air conditioning air
conditioning that's
that's a big one
um yeah more roof detail pipes and stuff
this is a pretty good example very dark
I wanna like this I feel like this is
what my scene feels like this is from
Mission Impossible
um
it'd be interesting to see what this
kind of look would look like
we have this natural light coming in
from it looks like the roof here
but who knows
it's tough to tell but it looks like
natural light of course we have the
windows in the background and everything
that really bring up this this Warehouse
and yeah this was my reference for
uh the inside right what this like array
would look like of TVs I want it to kind
of feel like this this is from Ash Thorp
incredible artist one of the best
here is the like mounting setup I want
to build out
and we can build that out really quick
in c4d
just a bunch of basic cubes and whatnot
I'm sure we can source that somewhere
but I might just build it out real quick
we'll see if I have time you know we're
halfway through this challenge
I wanted to also build out an
environment like this
that the character transports to Via a
VR setup to have all those monitors
Flicker and turn into this kind of
environment this was made with
mid-journey
a great way really great way to come up
with a bunch of ideas quickly
this is mid-journey as well
all right so I'm going to put this over
to the side
and be referencing this throughout the
video I'll pull it up as needed but
huh where do we start where do we start
um I know I said that we weren't gonna
really touch more on the lighting
but
I wonder if we were to rotate all of
these is there a way
in Unreal Engine where I can like select
all these and have them rotate
at their own pivot point or does it have
to be
like this
hmm
I guess I could just take all of these
guys
and rotate them
just to see what this looks like ah but
then it's virtually from there
shoot ah there we go
[Music]
it's kind of better
that way you can see the light there's
leading lines kind of cool
um but they need to be mounted to the
ceiling somehow they're not just
floating here
so we can work on that as well
all right
epoxo says you can rotate the pivot
of the mesh with modeling tools and they
will all rotate
sweet
very good to know
right and then we have like these
let's see lighting wise we have interior
lights
fluorescent bulbs okay
that's such a cool look
I love that
okay
um
I think we need like
if I were to look at this
reference here if you select the image
and hit spacebar again this is pure ref
it's a free program it helps uh build
reference for your projects you can
select a photo hit spacebar into a full
screen there's like
a bunch of different equipment
well really it's just this one right
here
this little like desk set up with some
monitors
really helps sell the fact that this is
like an operation and even back here
there's like a little a little setup
which is nice
and it would feel I think it would it
would be justified to to have like a
computer cart or just some equipment
carts maybe around cables running along
the floor
coming from this main area all these
cables are like
coming up to this main point and they
would be drawing the eye and leading the
eye to this main area just like you can
see these lines on the ground here
I like these lights turned this way
because it's all pointing everything is
pointing to the center to this character
and we can have all those cables running
in towards this thing and I think it
would be cool to just kind of
build out
this array set up from the inside out
meaning we start with the TV mounts
um and we go from there so
bunch of different ways we can source
that we can make it in c4d we could buy
one off of like CG Trader or something
um
we could photo scan something
um
but I think
what we'll do first is make sure that
the shape of these panels
is is what we are going for so do we
want it to be square
or do we want it to be rectangular and
I feel like Square
totally works I don't think there's a
reason to change it it's already here as
well
um
so knowing that I think we can go into
c4d and use let's see our reference here
and build out
A A system that we can copy and paste
across all of these things yeah
all right so I actually I took a photo
of a reference from a store the other
day
for this exact same thing too so let me
see if I can
pull that up really quick
yeah here we go
um
so this is kind of difficult to tell but
like this is the bottom of the TV I'm
looking up at this
and I just love this Mayhem behind here
there's a bunch of cables and
um extra little boxes and everything
attached to this
this is great I love this setup and I
want to build out like the back of this
monitor as well so
it doesn't need to be super detailed but
there needs to just be some basic blocks
back here and some parts that can really
just show off that there's a bunch of
stuff back here
um so
let me grab this reference
and
pop it into pure ref really quick
man this is why a three monitor setup is
crucial I got the stream stuff on this
side
I got the reference and the files on the
side and of course you're seeing my main
display here
all right
boom boom boom
okay
control n we'll start a new file and
let's just
make a cube and flatten it
and this will be like the back of our TV
setup
ah that works very nice let's give it
some
fill it
just to catch the Light a touch
in fact I'll do it with a bevel modifier
I'm gonna hit C to make that editable
and let's pull up our reference here
okay
hmm accordion
set up like this or
slider setup like this
I think from the side
maybe the accordion could be nice
okay
so I'll hold Ctrl and drag this back
foreign
my UV is all correct I'm just going to
make another Cube
and scale this down
something like that it'll be mounted
from this point
this will be the monitor itself
okay
very basic block out here of this setup
let's do
foreign
let's do another Cube
and this will be mounted
so imagine this as the TV itself right
this is the screen
let me get rid of this
grid as well
here we go
foreign
all right yeah let's open it up a little
bit
and let's go ahead and grab another Cube
t for scale
W for move and I'm just going to scrunch
this down so it's just like a longer
piece
I mean let me actually undo that
to make sure my proportions are correct
all scaled out this way then just scale
it down
and we're gonna throw this into a
symmetry
object or modifier or something like I
don't know the exact word for it but
symmetry that's what we want for sure
when we move it out
we want it to be symmetrical
why is it not working
you have to make it editable
we shouldn't have to
foreign
okay yeah I have to move the midpoint or
the axis itself to zero
said this is the world and we should
zero this out
and run it again
there we go there it works okay
so from here let us not adjust the axis
L is going to be the toggle between
adjusting the axis and adjusting the
object itself
[Music]
foreign
we can open this up a little bit more
and hold Ctrl let's see grab that object
of the entire object control drag it out
rotate it the other way
this will move down
we'll group these
so that
it's cloning both
boom all right
quick and dirty thorough
what's up hey man
um
thank you for the Super Chat you are
curious just like the rest of us how did
Corridor get hacked I have no idea
um who knows how they got hacked but
they got hacked and I think they got
their stuff fixed so that is a that is
great news
um
yeah I don't I don't know how they got
hacked
I don't who knows
maybe they know maybe they don't know
um
but I'm glad they got their stuff
figured out for those of you don't know
Corridor was packed over the last couple
days and
um basically
someone took control of their Channel
and posted a video
some like crypto Something Something
video
and they flagged it people flagged it so
much that the channel got shut down
and they just had to you know back and
forth with YouTube and you got their
stuff figured out so that is good very
good Thor I I wish I knew because I want
to protect myself as well
don't want to get hacked it's no good
okay let's grab a
cylinder t for scale
and
get rid of the height segments we don't
need them we can
crank the height Just a Touch
[Music]
very basic
very basic we'll throw that into the
null object as well
and that'll clone it to the other side
all right and then we're going to bring
all of this stuff up
boom all right so we're starting to get
there
we are starting to get there but I
noticed that we got to duplicate we
gotta duplicate
these bottom guys based off of the
reference
what's up
cylinder grows taller
just like that
foreign
it's gonna be so far away like
I don't think there's any point to do
insane levels of detail like we'll bevel
our edges for sure but like beyond that
it's pretty you know we're gonna be
dollying in like this and you're not
really gonna see
too much
um I think maybe one thing I will do
is man I could totally set up like a rig
for this that'd be pretty sweet
um thorough yet again
what's up brother thank you for the
Super Chat
um
you heard word on the street oh now it's
now it's uh
no it's he said she said let's see heard
it was a Bitcoin scam we gotta stop the
nft nonsense uh your fam produced one we
live in a society for God's sake
um
interesting so yeah I mean nfts have a
Bad Name a lot of shady people out there
doing it there's also good people out
there doing it heck I've done two of
them
um
technically three technically I've done
three
um
it's unfortunate that this is the case
and that it has such a bad name there's
a lot of people are just like oh I can
make money oh I can
take advantage of people and I don't
have a soul and I can like
steel X Y and Z my morals are just down
the tubes
um
unfortunately that's a thing yeah that's
a thing
it has a really bad name right now
um
and I think that there's just a lot of
baggage that comes with it unfortunately
so
who knows
who knows where it'll go but right now
it doesn't have the best best wrap for
it so
um
yeah
I don't know that's about that's about
all there is to say about that
um
all right moving on I want to open these
up a little bit more so let's go ahead
and grab
let this grab this guy
boom move it back a touch
like right in there and I'll just open
these out from
let's see
and grab both of those
something like that yep and the same
here
just open it up a little bit more
foreign
cool that works
that works for me
and we'll bring the cylinders in
thorough my goodness
my goodness thank you sir very much very
kind of you thank you thank you very
much
yeah it's unfortunate you know
which is unfortunate people taking
advantage
but I also know good people out there
doing it too so it's a tough one it's a
very tough one
the darkness overshadows the light
at this point
maybe one day it could be a brighter
future
but we can only we can only hope
there's probably other things we can do
too but
thank you again though
I was very very kind of you and yet
another one goodness
um
heck yeah man
I'm glad I'm glad that you're getting
paid for uh
for the things you're learning
for doing art that's great that's very
good news thank you sir thank you Thora
heck yeah
all right
what else this is like main detail stuff
um let's make some adjustments I will
grab these two and bevel them what is it
it's been a minute MW
is not the right MS
is the right one okay let's give
subdivisions three
yeah
that works for me
and we'll do the same up here
you
and here we're bevel in these edges
really beveling these edges
bam all right that looks that looks good
and then we can take each one of these
and throw a
bevel modifier on it
and bring it down to like point two and
goodness does that look janky probably
because
probably
because there's some like strange
geometry inside
no
but you know what I don't think it's
that big of a deal so I'm going to go
ahead and grab all these shift alt I
think we'll place the bevel individually
into all of them
and we can take that down to like point
two and that'll at least bounce a little
bit of light off of that edge because
they're beveled which is what we want
the cylinder same deal we hadn't made it
editable yet but we can uh
because of that we can just check Billet
Billet caps just a one
point two point two five perhaps that is
good for me we're gonna catch that edge
bevel we got more Super chats my
goodness it is popping off today thank
you all Arnold what's up
how do you keyframe an emissive material
like in the Billie Jean
Michael Jackson video when the floor
lights go up
boy there's a lot of ways
but I would say
that it's the same
way you'd keyframe anything else
um
I could demonstrate for you in two
seconds Brandon what you got
how do I make an artichoke
you strangle it oh my God the jokes on
this guy
oh oh boy
there's a level of like
feedback you get
when it comes to jokes of course you
know a loud laugh that's the best
um a little chuckle that's that's still
good
uh just just a just a little like huh
it's just beyond an exhale
and then you have the nostril breath
which is just like
maybe you go in there too but it's
mostly nostril breath that's when you
know it's pretty bad and if it's really
bad it's just silence
I'm the kind of guy
I gotta give you some feedback I can't I
can't just give you nothing
um I know sodomonte's cracking uh puns
all the time yeah to the when people get
annoyed because it's so bad and you
understand it and you're like oh it's so
bad that's for me it's the best reaction
you gotta hold your head you know like
because you had a mini migraine and you
might you might get a little nostril air
out of me
um but
yeah we're we're in the nostril air
territory at this point
um Arnold okay how do I key frame in a
missive it's the same same way you
keyframe anything let's make a cube
let's freaking make a material apply the
material
you're not seeing it because it's just
gray I guess uh let's make an octane
material
render the scene
um I'll quickly make a objects HDR
environment so it's just darkness which
means that is perfect for us because
we're going to make a material we're
going to create a diffuse material
there's a million ways to do this and in
all the other programs right so uh
inside of that material
um we don't even need to go inside we'll
go to emission and we'll make a
blackbody emission and there you go it's
glowing that is great we're going to
take the power up to 500.
it's really glowing okay awesome
um and then how do you key frame it well
keyframe has to do with time all right
so so if you could move my head up just
a little bit
um thanks and it has everything to do
with this timeline you key frame things
over time so on frame zero you see this
little Diamond here next to power if I
click that diamond it makes that
keyframe all right and that diamond
is on this material under the mission
right black body mission right then I go
forward and I say it's zero and then I
hit the keyframe again and if you scrub
through it turns it up very basic very
very basic
um like level one
is like key framing but it's you use
keyframes all the time
um and if you hit shift F3 and C40 you
can go into What's called the dope sheet
uh which I think is a stupid name
and you can drop us down and see the
actual like path of this right you can
see that they
they smooth out let me see if I can uh
drop this down how do I give myself more
room
God
I know there's like a there's a way but
I don't know how to do it at this point
any oh there we go I clicked something
right so you can really stretch these
out these are called
bezier curves so it starts real slow and
it goes oh ramps into it
or you can make it Linear by selecting
both of them and uh just making it
linear so it's just from one to zero
smooth and steady
animation
that is not my strong suit
but that is how a keyframe and emissive
generally it's the same across
every program so
good luck to you Arnold
good luck to you
all right
moving on
all right
we have this wall mount thing here I
don't know if I need to go beyond just
this
just the way it is right here like we
could add more detail we could always
add more detail later right but we want
to block out our stuff um this is what
connects us to the TV
honestly I don't think we need to add
anything in between here because we are
not going to see what's in between that
space
um but
I
like the idea of a bunch of cables
around this thing
um but I don't want the cables to look
I don't want them to look duplicated but
we'll do what we can alright
so the the cables are going from the
monitor to this this like Mount and then
we run cables down the wall this is
based off of
this guy here right we're running cables
down the wall
to you know some sort of server box like
this here in this ash Thorpe reference
um Cable's coming down off to cases and
computers like here in in uh Inception
Mission Impossible real clean really
clean they got a nice
nice setup here jealous of that setup
Inception also very clean but stuff like
this right like these little carts I
want this kind of stuff to be
in our environment so we'll get to that
point like I said we're working from the
central point
right we're working from this little
like room here out so we're starting
with the mount on the TV
um but wires okay wires let's get some
wires going
um
how are we going to do wires I know that
c4d has a really cool new like rope
Sim situation going on but honestly I
think that's overkill for what we're
trying to do we just need to set some
some ropes okay or some wires
so what I can do
again based off of our reference always
looking at reference we can see that
where are these wires going what are
they doing we have wires coming from the
TV
they're all coming from the TV they're
powering the TV right and we have these
extra boxes here that maybe we can add
an extra antenna or something but that's
probably some DirecTV
but the cables are going from the TV
to this Mount and down right and they're
all zip tied to it so knowing that we we
need
something coming out of this TV
wrapping around this system
and going
either up down left or right and I think
I can just
have them go into
I don't know
I think they can just go into this thing
I don't think we need to spend any more
time than just adding cables so we're
going to go to a top down View
and I'm hitting I believe middle click
um
the only reason I say believe is because
I'm using a pen wake up pen here
but we'll hit middle click and that's
going to open up all of our viewers and
middle click again
to go full screen on the one we want now
let's see
pen tool great you know what we can
probably do is freehand this thing but
freehand ooh it adds a bunch of like a
bunch of points we probably don't want
um
I'm just gonna try clicking here
click in here
click in here
and clicking here that probably doesn't
look good I'll hit escape to close it
I'm going to grab all these hit zero
that's gonna bring up our uh
our rectangular selection tool I'll
select them all we're gonna turn these
two
where are you hard interpolation which
means they don't bend or anything
and then in the spline options if I go
to the object I can set the type
to bezier cubic right so cubic can
totally work for what we're doing it's
just the way they Bend right there's a
bunch of different options on how they
Bend
subdivided but I think oh sorry I'm in
the wrong one
bezier we don't want bezier because
that's like
it's gonna take too long to adjust all
that stuff we want it to be as quick and
auto as possible
so akima can work cubic can work either
one of those is fine but how do we
thicken it up right we need a
Circle spline boom that's how I think
it's going to be so hit t for scale
scale it way down
way down
it doesn't need to be positioned
anywhere fancy it just needs to be in
the world and we're going to select both
the spline and the circle hold Ctrl Alt
and holding Control Alt is going to
allow us to whatever whatever we select
here
it's gonna be the sweep it's going to
automatically make whatever we select a
parent of the things we have selected
that makes sense
I hit T scale it down
that's a lot of Geo we don't need that
much so I'll go to I believe it's it's a
two-pronged thing
controlling the amount of uh Geo here is
between the sweep and the circle so if I
go to the spline itself and hit one
honestly that's
yo
that'll probably do as well
but
I mean dank should I
I mean honestly
we got more Super chats in the house my
goodness y'all thank you
dang okay
all right all right all right
let's take a look here we got
shinivari I recognize that name
maybe you've been here before anyone
have any tutorials that would help with
the challenge I'm a beginner and it's a
little difficult to find what I need
well shinivari that is a very general
question
very very general question what do you
need help with like character stuff
animation materials lighting there's so
many like what program are you in
there's a million
million different things so if you could
be a little bit more specific I don't
think you gotta super chat again but
just at
Punisher hit me with ad Punisher in this
chat and just give me a little bit more
description of what you're working with
and what you're looking for and even if
I don't see it I think the people in the
chat can help you out if you're in
blender
blender Guru is like the first go-to one
right the donut tutorial
um also check out Ian Hubert if you're
in Cinema 4D
um I love grayscale gorilla that's how I
learned uh octane Jesus he's another guy
who uses c4d
um EJ from I design I design like your
eyeball Eye Design that's a great one
for c4d
um there's a lot of good ones you just
you know
YouTube stuff if you're in Unreal Engine
William Foshay is amazing that's
f-a-u-c-h-e-r voucher but it's
pronounced Foshay William Foshay uh wind
Bush also another great guy for c4d and
Unreal Engine
um
those are my go-to's to be honest with
y'all
other than that I'm just finding random
people putting out random videos
sometimes I'll stumble upon the same
person
um
but those are my go-to's
uh and then we got another Super Chat we
got VJ yo VJ what is good it has been a
minute thank you so much very kind of
you
um no message
attached even it's just it's just hype
thank you thank you so much
thank you very much
super generous of you
y'all are great
you all are fantastic
carried me through my masters yeah
William push is the best
um sanim hey good question okay hey
Clint just wondering do you consistently
have to watch tutorials while working on
a project being a professional or is it
just a beginner thing dude I am watching
tutorials 24 7. I kid you not like for
what I'm doing right now obviously I'm
working on this deserves full screen
um let's get some more light in here
just a little bit more
um yeah dude I'm watching tutorials all
the time
the more you do something the less
tutorials you have to watch but like you
know at this point I've done so many
muzzle flashes in After Effects I could
do them with my eyes closed
um
I
I don't know I've I've done octane
material stuff so much that I could and
like surface imperfections that I could
not with my eyes closed but I could do
it without tutorials
unless they got updates then you got
more tutorials right but man
it's VFX is like
50 no more than 50 50. it's like 70
troubleshooting
30 art
and right when you begin it's like
98 troubleshooting
two percent art and the tutorial
tutorials are a great way
to do both at the same time
um
when you're watching a good tutorial
that's really walking you through step
by step
you're getting 50 50. you're learning
you're troubleshooting but it's a very
like hand-holdy way to troubleshoot
um you're kind of being told hey here's
what the problem is and here's how to
solve it immediately and you get results
because it's a tutorial you know you get
a result by the end of the tutorial and
all the way through
um those are people like I design like
octane Jesus like uh like wind Bush
um like grayscale gorilla like William
Foshay you know these people are putting
out tutorials that are solid
but then when you break out of the
tutorial Zone that's like another thing
that's another step
when you're not creating art that is in
the tutorial you're creating art that is
coming from your mind or coming from a
photo you took or coming from you you're
creating your own art at that point
that's when the tutorial the tutorial
shift you're still watching tutorials in
fact you're watching more tutorials but
it's not a handholdy tutorial you have
to
you're you're coming across your own
problems
and you're looking up tutorials on
YouTube or whatever
and you're getting you're spending a ton
of time looking for very specific
answers for very specific problems
and then you run into the next problem
and the next problem and the next
problem and you have to keep looking up
tutorials and keep troubleshooting and
when you break out of the like
yeah I mean I just said it like when you
when you break out of making art that
are in that's in tutorials and you go
into making your own art that's when the
tutorials ramp up even more so
um so I'm I'm watching tutorials all the
time this whole last week I was watching
tutorials on Daz
um I was watching tutorials in c4d on
how to simulate cloth I was watching
Rococo tutorials
on how to like pair my character mesh to
the mocap data and not have it look
janky like this tutorial City 24 7. so
it can be very frustrating
it can feel very daunting it can feel
like
you can feel not fun
um
but when you solve the problem it's a
great feeling so I encourage you to keep
it up
um
and
and keep at it because it'll it'll pay
off for sure and then the more you do it
you don't have to follow tutorials
you'll be like like me when with muzzle
flashes I've done so many at this point
that like
yeah
um and there's still a blast they're
still really funny too
so good luck hang in there it's tutorial
Town 24 7.
it's the best
Soto do you have any any insight on that
uh on that little tidbit there or um how
do you feel about it I think you gave
great like a great explanation
um I would say if you're still having
travel finding like an answer to a
specific thing I joined the Discord and
asking the voice chats probably someone
will help you there
um but yeah other than that pretty good
pretty good info
yeah you know got to plug my own stuff
too yes we have a Discord server um
and there's a there's a ton of artists
in there I think we hit 50K
uh recently we hit 50k and
50k people
and
it's live all the time it's Live 24 7.
there's people from India there's people
from the US there's people from the UK
there's people from from Asia it's like
all over the place right
um and y'all can hop in and ask
questions
it's literally for that so
good luck
anurag thank you
thank you for the super chat
um and we also have say polar bears
y'all are popping off with the super
chats today thank you so much
that's great uh it says question to all
if I'm going to be going into the video
game development industry should I start
learning unreal
uh I'm currently a blender user
I mean
usually I'm not like you should learn
one program or another
but um
yeah I mean if you're going into the
gaming industry it's either Unity or
unreal right like maybe there's other
stuff but I'm not a I'm not in the game
industry so I don't know
but I do know that unity and unreal are
like the top ones
in my mind
um
some of my favorite games were made with
unreal
I'm sure a lot of them were made with
unity as well
um but I would say absolutely if you're
trying to get into gaming then
definitely pick up unreal look up
William Foshay look up wind Bush they
got you some tutorials
um
I got some tutorials as well
so
who knows maybe if you get in they'll be
like where we use Unity only and then
that's still okay because you know you
use uh you pick up knowledge in
Unreal Engine that it will carry over to
Unity so you're not wasting your time or
anything
but the other day it's you do because
you have fun right so
keep it up all right wires cables back
to it
go to point mode
all right move these around
and this is how our wires work we can
Let's see we can turn off the circle
spline that way we can actually see
where our points are at
hey you know
zero is your rectangular selection tool
and we're gonna have wires coming off of
this TV all right so where do the wires
come from they probably come from like
where you plug the HDMI into which is
let's just for for our sake say it's off
to the left here
um
so I'm just going to move that into the
TV
and it's going to
come down here we're gonna like move it
over here and it's all going to go to
I'll say like
the middle
of this thing
something like that
right
and we can probably thicken up the wires
just a little bit to see a bit more of
them
and let's make a couple more shall we so
let's do uh
can I do like this can I just duplicate
that
doesn't work like that does anyone let's
find out
yeah it won't do two at the same time
but maybe if I group this
doesn't seem to work like that either
okay
foreign
I know it would do it I think if I
okay
yeah that's that's not what we want
I'm just gonna duplicate The Sweep
itself for now
and we'll move this around so okay so we
got
one coming from there we got a power
cable let's do a power cable from the
bottom
so let's do yeah power cable from down
here
this will be a thicker one so we can
actually give it some more thickness
and we'll have this one kind of like
wrap
around the this thing
so it'll come like
up and through
like that
and I'll just go to the center again
nice and we'll give that some more
thickness because it is the power cable
so it's going to be thicker
awesome
and we got more cables we got like um
another let's say another HDMI signal so
let's do let's duplicate this
for HDMI
right and we can say boom that's our
second HDMI slot
and this one could droop down a little
lower
hang down like this
I'm looking at what it's going to look
like from like back here because this is
really the angle we're going to be
viewing it from
let's take the power cable and maybe
give it like
just a little bit more
like that
foreign
[Music]
looking at our reference
yeah let's do like a squirrely one so
that's going to be a couple more points
right
um let's take one of these
coming from the other side right so
let's first start by selecting all them
control a for the points we'll move it
over here
and we'll have it coming out from like
this side
and maybe down here
who knows what this is
and let's
pipe that into there
and let's try and give it like a couple
more
couple more
blind points here
let's see I think if I actually just
like this in hey uh you owe or no oh
us it'll subdivide it yep
so you just add one in between that's
literally what that did we can do the
same we'll just do it as needed actually
[Music]
foreign
select both of these we'll hit us the
way I think of it us either way I
remember it is like
it it spells us right so us means more
more people
and you're making more of us if you
or geometry if you uh hit us
the Dumber those like little
memorization things get the easier it is
to memorize to be honest
sweet all right so we got some cables
looking good the only issue is like if
it looks like it's duplicated and it
probably will and I'm going to solve
that later
a cheap way for making variations is
just flipping it in the x-axis Maybe
totally yeah so you could do like uh
and select all these group them
alt G
um
[Music]
and just flip it up you have to type it
in it seems
let's see here coordinates
negative one
so the difference between that
and that yeah that's variation enough
for sure
so what you could do is export
one of these
and another so just have two variations
um
all right so
let's take this
save it
and I'm going to export this as
an fbx
[Music]
don't need any of that stuff
just uh subdivision surface is hmm
he's a sweep counted as a subdivision
service
no
but we'll find out
all right
save this
foreign
models
this is a
TV mount
one
and then we'll flip that axis again
negative one and we'll save this file
export fbx
TV mount two
we'll bring it into
Unreal Engine
Matt Walker what's up control Z is your
best friend just try stuff out yeah
that is a very good point
we can undo to the end of time when it
comes to 3D
actually not not actually but but
control Z does exist so
I agree with you test things out your
first idea is not always your best
so get them all out of there and uh
you got to mind for those good ideas
Ctrl Z is your friend
thank you Matt thanks for that uh that
heads up
all right
now let us apply these here to
all of these monitors I wish there was
an easier way
I'm sure there's a way to do it with
like
in c4d
in fact I know there's a way to do it in
c4d
but
I'm doing it none religion
call me stubborn all right mesh let's go
to mesh props
and let's drag our fbx in shall we
start with TV mount number one and I
want to combine meshes so it's just one
thing
um
build nanite yes please
and I think it's going to try and bring
in materials
I don't want to create a material
because I'll do that later and I don't
want to import textures so import all
great we got a decent view of our TV but
I after I figured this one out
it's been it's been all about this go to
settings thumbnail edit mode and if you
gosh dang it wait what
I'm gonna let it mode
should
oh yeah just click and drag just click
and drag
right you find the best angle that like
that really shows off what this thing is
all right I think that works
so that's TV mount one
TV mount two same deal the import
settings will stay
and we'll go back to that thumbnail edit
mode left click
yeah
that's great so it brings
foreign
okay
we could have solved that in the import
ant but I'm lazy so let's go ahead and
man maybe we do need to do this in the
import
ant okay let's try it in the import
let's try it in the important
um we can bring both of them in at the
same time
and if you go to
[Music]
import scale it's set to 100. let's set
that to one
thumbnail edit mode
awesome we get it yeah done
yay okay this is way more doable let's
set it to 0.5
.4 0.4 looks like it's the way and a
space bar to toggle between your
position scale and rotation
and I'm going to line this up with the
TV itself you notice my my UVS are off
right
but I'm not too worried because I'm
probably just gonna have this be like a
reflective black
material
now let's see if this was even worth it
because like I I want these to be seen
right
we hope all
we can duplicate these screens
and I'll actually do them
one every other because
we have those duplicate ones right
bring this in
set it to 0.4 as well
[Music]
there we go and these trusses
I have this like
post-process material lens Distortion
thing on right now
right and it makes it difficult to
actually select things you can see if I
select it the actual like outline
for its selection doesn't match until I
turn it off so
if you were if you followed uh last
week's stream you saw that tutorial was
in the description
foreign
having trouble selecting stuff boom all
right so all of our cables can run down
the scaffolding
yeah let's go to this
set up here
G will show or hide things see how like
small that is
but they do exist they are there
let's go ahead and
uncheck game settings yeah this is a
little bit
a little bit better
these are going to be up top as well so
let's
alt drag this up
we all we also can cheat and just like
do that to get a little bit more
um which may not be a bad idea but first
let's let's duplicate these across the
board yeah
foreign
our snapping is on top right you see
this little button right here this is
our snapping
and it's very handy for rotating things
like we're doing
all right so we got that and then let's
alt drag again to duplicate even further
we'll go 90 on it
not 85.
boom
I'm using q and E well actually I'm
holding right click and I'm using w a s
and D to move around and then q and E
will raise and lower so I'm just kind of
getting in here
where are my Gizmo oh I gotta hit w
Anna line it up nice
let's go
alt drag to the other side
line it up nice and then we just got one
more to do
or right here
foreign
if they need to actually be flush
yeah I feel like they actually need to
be
blush because
you're seeing a little bit more
these down
that's pretty sweet yeah it's some
subtle detail but it adds most
definitely this is going to be in some
full screen
printed out all nice
sweet
maybe we can go a step back I don't know
how necessary that's gonna be because at
a certain point you're not going to be
seeing these monitors anymore
but I feel like this top row
in fact I'm gonna grab all these TV
mounts right
and let's pop them in a folder top right
here if you click that
um TV mount
right
and if we select all them TV mounts
I'm not even going to group them and I'm
just going to hold alt and drag them
back
and see the you know do we see that or
not
we do all right
from here this is our this is our
furthest angle
and I think I can go one more I can go
one more because we will technically see
one more row
cool
so all these wires we have to run all
these wires and like populate this with
wires and stuff we'll figure that out
but now that I think of it here here's
actually
so it's not perfectly duplicated with
all these wires right
here's what we'll do
is I will grab
all of these mounts again and
when I duplicate them
I'll actually rotate them to
and I think that should give us a
different look
yep
yep yep yep yep
and we'll do it again
with the rotate
dude what
mm template C oh I put it in the
sequencer what the heck
somehow it ended up in the sequencer and
had a keyframe made for itself that's
funny
let's make a material for this thing so
I'll go to materials and
we have basic material
imperfections okay so that is a material
instance I'm going to make another
well since I'm not using this I'll just
apply it to the TV so what we can do
is actually go to our TV
we'll search for our TV right so you can
see this little search that'll show us
where it is if I double click it
it'll open up the asset itself and if we
apply
that material to this asset it should
populate to all of them right and
they'll come out with that material
so
should pop it in there
nice all right and then we have the
other one as well so I'll select that
open it up
and pop in that material
I'm gonna make them black
right so I'll go for
base color
take that down
and let's see
specular
just a little bit
metallic
do we want metallic
roughness intensity
yikes
so I didn't set up my roughness as nice
as I would like to
because I want it you can see like even
if I go
Max intensity it still doesn't get like
a huge majority of this so I think that
just has to do with my master material
setup
I think it's okay for now let's just see
what this does see what this looks like
and it's honestly you know it's just
dark
when we get to here you'll see a little
bit more of it but
I think that's fine
we can take the base color up a little
bit perhaps
that's actually pretty cool I like that
it's almost I mean it's basically Chrome
foreign
[Music]
all right let's grab the scaffolding and
see if we can't start connecting
[Music]
these monitors to the scaffolding
somehow
so I'm gonna get it like
right up to
this thing
there's somewhere in there
same here
and I can probably just like make
a wire asset in c4d
and have it like just have it be kind of
a long wire asset and just run it around
and across
this whole system here and we can just
scale it
and have it be as long as we want and
that'll give us more detail
sweet
because the wires are going to come off
of this
and around the trusses so let's go back
to c4d
right this is looking nice I'm gonna
make a new file
um I'm just going to call this one
long
cables
and let's make a figure to know like
what scale we're dealing with these guys
come in at two meters
I'll make a cylinder
R for rotate shift for uh snapping
and that's the longest I think we'll
need to make one of these things we can
we can probably do there because we know
we're gonna make some short ones too so
we can find something in the middle
and let's go ahead and
go to our top down View
point mode in fact I'm gonna copy over
one of these sweeps
because we don't need to make it again
it's already done right
and I'm gonna just leave it to two
points
to make it easy
start at the end and we'll take this out
to the other end
and I'm gonna go through here
and with both points selected I'm going
to subdivide this and you can right
click
and select subdivide or you can use the
shortcut us this is what we talked about
earlier I'm hit us that means we got a
subdivision right here in the middle
so with that I will well first
we'll keep this at the bottom
because it's coming from the bottom and
it's going to wrap around
to the top
I also like both of those again we're
going to
everything we're going to
get this
to wrap around
like so in fact this one would
technically come over here to this side
so that way we have a cord wrapping
around
all of this now
we're going to keep subdividing it
to give a little bit of uh
variation in what we're doing
as if it's zip tied down
to this so every other one is like zip
tied down right
that one's real snug and then this one
opens up
and that one's real snug
and that one's really snug and we can
just keep going so I'll take that and
subdivide again
kind of just randomly
moving these around
and I wanted to like wrap actually to
wrap more so around this thing so
let's keep
let's just keep it going
it's that detail work baby
I think we'll do it once and then we can
have it to duplicate
nice
so that could be a variation and then we
could have another one
it might be
if I were to delete all these again we
can start fresh and we can
make one more variation
a little closer to maybe what we had
before where maybe they're all just kind
of running
along the
the top let's say they're all running
along the top
right and we'll break this up
have these come up and out just a little
bit do it again
bring them back a touch
and instead of the top maybe it's the
side so I'll hold shift
we'll go 90 on it and then just kind of
Bring It Back
let me like that
foreign
so looking at
our scene
um
the wires are going to run basically
across this down this we'll duplicate it
right so there's a bunch of wires
running down and then they'll probably
come from this point
and the wires will run to somewhere to
some sort of like Central
unit of some sort
um control unit and that will be stuff
kind of like this
it'll be stuff kind of like this and
it'll be stuff kind of like
this
right and
oh we got Steve begin up in here yo
what's up Steve
we got my unreal Sensei he was the one
who took the time to teach me every
Friday for a few hours before work what
up Steve
dude
come a long way since you've taught me
all right we got a bunch of monitors in
here
surface imperfection I remember when we
went over surface imperfections now
granted these aren't as clean as they
can be I was moving fast all right you
gotta trust
um
we're gonna bring in some some ropes and
stuff or cables rather got like nice
emissive but you know you know I ain't
trying to light a whole scene with
emissives because that's not right I got
lights hidden in here well this one
should be movable I got lights up in
here to help light our scene you know I
would never do that with emissives same
up here too we got a little Miss of
bulbs but nah you know I'm not trying to
do that I got all these other lights
light in the scene
I've learned a lot Steve you taught me
very much
you taught me very much is that even
what is that
you taught me well
also Steve check this out
um we got a post-process material that
does lens Distortion look at the right
side of frame
all adjustable too
where is it down here somewhere
boom here it is
right for some reason does not work with
exrs or pngs I think it only works with
jpegs perhaps
but
kind of cool you know you get a subtle
enough look
and uh and it totally works out
two Moss
two Moss
what is up greetings from Finland
hello Finland I have been following
along for a year now in the chill
atmosphere has been great for learning
hey that is what's up I'm glad it's
chill I'm glad chill and my channel are
words that go together
um let's see how much my first try at
the challenge runs out or oh wait hold
on let's see how much my first try at
the challenge
Runs Out of Time Runs Out
uh you got it man you got it you're
gonna do great
um
I will say this much to y'all
um
if you're feeling like you're behind
it's okay we're only halfway through
this thing
if you hadn't started yet
and you want to it's not too late you
can still dive in
um you don't have to create your
Masterpiece all right it's just fun to
create and to be a part of these
montages and whatnot yes we will have
people shooting for that top 100 we will
have people shooting for top five we
will have people shooting for first
place
um but just because there are people
pushing themselves to get that
um and you feel you're not ready enough
or you're not you're not there quite yet
don't let that bum you out from just
hopping in and creating something and
having fun it can just be a little tiny
thing small little thing as long as
you're learning and having fun that's
the whole point and then we put it all
together in that Montage to come
together as a 3D community so
yeah keep it up have fun with it
um
what was your name again Tomas
Thomas tumas thank you for the Super
Chat best of luck to you uh shout outs
to Finland maybe one day I'll make my
way down there
all right
so I think the next thing that we got to
do is
finish our thought in c4d
I think we have
some cables that are looking good we can
bring these in it's gonna be great all
right so we'll make these editable
and
from here let's go file export fbx
keep yourself organized models we have
long cables and I'm saving them together
because we can import them together or
sorry import them separately by
unchecking that box right so we'll go to
mesh we'll go to props
and we will import our long cables
making sure
see I'll build nanite yes
um
I want to uncheck
combined meshes because I want the
individual options
um import scale that is one should be
one
and I don't want to create a materials
import all
and let's
see if we can get that thumbnail edit
mode if you left click I think or right
click
there we go you can zoom in on it so
that is probably the best view for our
cable something like that and we'll do
the same here
Steve I had no idea about this thumbnail
edit mode this is amazing
all right those are
those are our cables done editing
all right
let's bring them on out
you know it'll bring them out together
they're a team
all right
let's get them in place dude those are
some greasy monitors
but we're not seeing him from there
we're seeing him from here and I can
adjust it as I as I need to but those
are some fine-tuned adjustments I don't
need to work on them that's too fine for
me
all right
let's
space bar stretch these out to the
extent of the scaffolding
foreign
and I'm pretty sure the squiggly one was
supposed to be on the bottom started on
the bottom and this one started
right in the front
and I can go to these guys and give them
the appropriate material
can I open both of these yes I can
materials
boom
it's got the surface imperfection
one we'll save that and save that and
now they have the correct material
which
you know we can adjust this as needed
later
you know what though you know what
though you know what though let's set
this to Yellow
or orange
um there was one of these references
that had some of that in here yes like
this
I love those accents I think this even
had a touch of
yellow orangish
as well that I really like so getting
some cables to feel like that
I think could be sweet so I'm gonna take
off the metallic and I'm gonna set the
base color
to Yellow
well that okay that screwed things up a
little bit um
let's undo that let's make a new
material instance holding Ctrl
I lied holding alt nope I lied holding
alt and what
control C control V
okay that works
um let's open up them cables again and
give it this new one shall we
so you know what nah dude
I'm just gonna drag and drop it because
I'm sure other some cables will be one
color another cable be another color
that works let's take off chrome the
metallic will take it off let's set it
to Yellow
and I think we can take the roughness
uh well let's find out first
that way can I I can actually see
what the heck these cables are doing
I could place them a little bit better
this way
[Music]
foreign
there we go
and we can duplicate these and run them
down
it's post process
it's throwing them off my selection uh
get
all right
bam
bam
alt drag
it down
rotate it
scale it
[Music]
and maybe I'll put these like
toward the back or something
but that looks honestly that looks
pretty sweet
it's starting to look more like a lab
which I am all about
hold alt and you should be able to
duplicate these guys
and flip them around give us a different
kind of look to it
we just got cables on cables
coming down this thing I'm going to
duplicate it on the other side as well
it's just cable town
running down these guys
sweet
let's grab
these cables and bring them over to the
other side
I'm gonna let's see let's pop this
uh I don't know I'll leave it as is for
now
hold alt bring it over
lip em
180
space bar to toggle between
your position scale and rotation gizmos
[Music]
and there's going to be clipping all
right at the end of the day there's
going to be some clipping but
we can make these fine adjustments
as we go through our art
all right
you know you can also do like
bundles of of rope too
foreign
so we could do um
let's see I'll make a new one
and
we'll make a circle we'll actually make
two circles
one of them will be way scaled down
we'll select both can hold Ctrl alt and
pop him into a sweep
and if we make these editable
see how many points we got four points
that's perfect that's exactly what we
need I'll basically
just kind of like
bring them in towards each other
open it up a little bit
always spawn a person to know what scale
we're dealing with so I want to keep the
Rope
I keep saying rope the cable's pretty
small
so that's good here
and I'll make a couple more of these
let's take
this down to zero
right and we'll make a couple more I
think we only need like
three
and we'll just kind of adjust the
scale this a little bit
more circular and
maybe this comes forward a touch
this come goes back a touch
and then this final one can be like
even longer
and then we'll stack them
so the tops are aligned
and let's
duplicate them control drag them back
bring them up a little bit maybe hmm
thank you
scrunch them in
open them up a little bit
I mean honestly that's not bad just
having the one we can duplicate it later
in unreal I think
but that looks that looks good to me
um let's take it and
that totally works let's export this
uh cable Loop
and we want to make sure this comes in
as one combined mesh
and let's also make sure if we double
click it
it has the correct material attached
foreign
foreign
[Music]
and we can kind of position these all
around
always be checking like from where
you're going to be viewing this thing
foreign
I also feel like if there's going to be
TVs on the bottom like that it should
technically be raised up onto a platform
so I wonder how deep I want to go with
that
foreign
this looks great
really happy with how this is turning
out big fan of this detail yeah I think
um
it would definitely need to be raised up
on something but
I don't know maybe I'll come back
with that because
it's gonna be a lot
I feel like there also would be okay we
need to block this out
from large to small we're getting pretty
detailed here I'm I'm happy with how
this is turning out
um
the next thing would be
the hubs and control units that the
cables are going to
so
so I wonder if there's any like cart
assets I'm sure there's some stuff
um
let's check the
Marketplace and see what we got
also shout outs to everybody for
sticking with me we got 540 people
strong in this thing
um
we're doing some good stuff we're doing
some good work
appreciate y'all
I can maybe take it to the chat here and
uh do a little mini q a
before we dive back in but
let's look at all the stuff I got
um look at all this look at all the
stuff I got uh okay
[Music]
uh
construction site volume one what is
this
hmm
boxes
and stuff okay boxes and stuff
tarps
Arps could be a thing pallets
it's warehousey
I think we're good on this stuff this
chain link fences are kind of creepy
though maybe
now
okay maybe not
construction site that is what I was
hoping for though
um
wait scans Construction Construction
Site what is this
it's like rubble and stuff
pretty sweet but not what we need I'm
looking for okay apartment Tech props
this is from The Matrix setup this is
exact this is pretty much what I need
foreign
yeah tables with computers and wires
this is a lot of props
a lot of props
my goodness
oh that cable asset alone yo that this
cable asset alone is so worth it these
random like
yeah this is this is pretty
close
to what I need monitor wise we might go
for more of a
more of a higher text situation
but I think
getting this kind of look here
can be possible with this
um
so that's cool we can easily add that
let's do uh Library
add to project
add to project
it's going to do its thing let's see if
there's anything else we could use
Bridges bicycle buildings people
vehicles
foreign
construction site volume 2.
we got some tables and stuff
um
chainsaw this like
a thing of cables here could be nice oh
here here's a a pile of cables that
could actually come in handy
but I feel like we can just make that on
our own really quick as opposed to
importing all of this stuff
what else we got
um Landscapes fantasy horror dining room
Meadow
low poly Asian environment low poly cats
industrial hanger okay
oh this is like some exterior stuff I
don't think this is really
but we need oh man it is inside too it's
massive
ah what else do we got what else do we
got
neighborhood modern modular industrial
area
okay this is all for free by the way uh
every month they have like five things
for free on this Marketplace
ah this is a little
not quite oh
these little guys here could be a thing
there might be a couple things in here
we could use
pipes and stuff
[Music]
um
I'll add it
hmm office
maybe the office maybe they got some
computers in the office
yeah there's some real there's a real
basic monitor but
this will be like gigs and gigs I I'd
rather just bring make that really quick
in c4d
um
hmm valid ancients unreal blah blah
supermarket
Seoul City
God that's a lot of stuff
okay
not quite what we need
not quite
[Music]
um
sci-fi polar City what is this last one
okay that's some stuff here
I think I'm good
we'll work with what we got
[Music]
The Matrix pack is in it's done
we got the Matrix desk uh apartment
meshes
sweet
sweet sweet
yeah let's like start figuring out where
these main clusters of gear and Tech
will be and then we can run wires to
those points basically we're going to
need like a
a control area
um
I'm not quite sure where that's going to
be but we're going to figure it out
so we're starting here
and
foreign
dude totally just the freaking
toolbox
with some stuff on it
oh oops
like why not you know like
someone we can populate so much of this
stuff
um but let's focus let's focus
oh sorry Focus went out the window these
wires
that is glorious
I feel like these dudes would be like a
little bit more organized
whoever's running this operation
but that honestly looks kind of cool
and we could
also just give this
that yellow material
see if I double click this yep it's got
that
that's great that's freaking great
what's this
a bunch of disconnected wires all right
all right I'll drag we'll get this over
here
hmm okay
this was lowered
it was up on a stage platform like I
feel like
that would be a bit more accurate
um
be a lot of things to select
let's stay focused stay focused stay
focused all right we need to get those
little islands of monitors that we can
run the cables to
I feel like we're gonna need a bigger
desk than that but this desk is a little
as high tech as I would like
foreign
little areas to monitor
it's going down
and I'm gonna switch this chair out for
sure because I don't want it to just be
this freaking Matrix scene
definitely don't want people recognizing
assets
a little close
foreign
desks are the way to go
because it just makes more sense
oh that's great
that is just great
no
no
oh
God
terrifying
yeah this dude's desk setup is freaking
sweet
super high tech
let's see what this would look like if
we gave it
keyboard
give it a monitor
we'll obviously have to
flatten down
uh
foreign
like this kind of stuff
is perfect
because you're like what is this some
sort of high-tech operation is going
down
all for it
oh that's a printer okay
foreign
foreign
like you would definitely need a person
like monitoring this thing too you need
another actor in there
foreign
you could also have like
okay so all these TVs will be plugged in
I need some sort of power source
and I think that's what we're missing
right now we need like a big
old power source
um
so I know we brought in
this Industrial Area
um
just this little forklift
foreign
depends like how much you really want to
fill it out you could go to town and do
this kind of setup
should be a lot of work
rather keep it a little bit more simple
but
who knows
but we don't need that forklift right
now
what we do need
oh some good pipes
power cable
Transformer maybe this Transformer
that's probably an outside thing huh
these switchboards yes yes yes
this kind of stuff
huh
foreign
they could be up against the wall but
like
I feel like the space is so vast
it does look kind of cool though
foreign
yo thank you for the Super Chat you
gotta run but I'm glad you enjoyed it
thank you very much for stopping by I'm
glad the chat was useful for you
I'm glad we did some stuff that uh that
helped you out so I'll see you next time
next week we got two more live streams
to continue working on this art
thank you very much for that Super Chat
Kaylee
foreign
it could be like right up on it though
too at the same time
foreign
along the back wall too though
foreign
hmm
yeah I feel like it just needs a
it needs junk and junk is tough because
there's so much detail in it
foreign
maybe change the colors of these things
to like a blue
uh opacity roughness ambient occlusion
no
we're looking for emissive there it is
emissive color here we go boom
this guy
so we can give this a
tint
we'll hold three and click make a color
we'll hold M for multiply
let me pop this into RGB and this goes
into the multiply
this is the intensity right if we take
this to one
those lights will dim down
very dim I think that actually takes
them off
but we'll go back to five and then I'll
take this to a blue
see what happens
huh
nothing at all I wonder why
foreign
there we go
skyrix dreamer thank you for the Super
Chat you got a question so he says Hey
Clint super quick can we make the camera
Shake in mid transition of the animation
it's the same camera animation but I
would like to Make It Shake in the
middle and then stop yes you can do that
as long as
you don't have a ton of cameras like as
long as you have a ton of camera Shake
um in your scene so it's super jarring
that's fine
um and as long as it doesn't affect the
like looping aesthetic
from one render to another
yes you can add camera Shake just go
easy on it
um
yeah it's up to you it's up to you how
much how much you add so
good luck and thank you for that Super
Chat very kind of you
I'm excited to see your render I'm
excited to see all your guys's renderers
yes if y'all are working on your render
right now for this challenge give me a
thumbs up in the chat let me see them
thumbs
ah
I'm excited to see your guys's stuff so
definitely stop by Monday
on the Discord because we're going to be
going over your art you can submit your
art we'll bring you up on the stage
we'll talk about it
um
and yeah fill in the community on how
you're doing so far nor you are working
away default's going heck yeah
good to see you all working on your
stuff easy Sonics is going
Jack
Yani Ben
Chris kasora
yes light storm
we got everybody
Francisco you're scared you got this son
fiza yay everyone's working on their
stuff
easy science yes we are talking about
Works in progress on Monday yeah
absolutely
Bring it on Bring it on
all right I wonder if I do this instead
ah it doesn't do it huh
um I wonder if
something like
this would work
I'm just trying to get blue to show
through instead of green and red could
quickly do it in Photoshop but I'm
trying to figure out the best way to do
it here
in unreal
hmm
yeah I don't know
maybe that's a quest for another day
small detail
multiply the color over top
oh like after this
foreign
[Music]
foreign
weird
oh it's gonna be the whole thing
shoot
yeah that's not gonna work
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
let's hang these lights it's about time
we hang these things
we get some pipes on the ceiling as well
[Music]
foreign
foreign
I wonder if chains
should do it with chains
hmm
foreign
default you're saying you're thinking a
copper pipe rig for the lights
let's see
all right
yeah I can see that
I think we actually have some pipes
in our Mega scans assets
metal beams
what's this
oh okay
yeah yeah yeah
we could do this here perhaps
foreign
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
and shrink it down
[Music]
foreign
let's get up into its material instance
and see if we can't give it like more of
a copper color
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
I am colorblind but I think that is what
we're going for
um
let's give it more specular
and let's take the roughness down to 0.2
.5
let's see what that looks like
I think that works yeah
all right so technically
I wanna
just delete these probably
and repopulate it
with this new one
hmm let's Let's uh
okay okay
foreign
thank you
sweet all right
foreign
foreign
foreign
just testing to see what this looks like
we don't need the far ones
the heck
foreign
is coming together
that is not bad not bad at all
foreign
let's see if we can get some more pipes
up on the the roof here
we can probably
use there's a couple references here
there's
this one which is like these are water
pipes
I would assume
that would be scaffolding but these are
water pipes
for
fire stuff
yeah these are all water pipes so
let's go and make a water pipe asset
shall we
[Music]
foreign
this out
a few times
but in fact let's uh
let's take a look
here all right so every so often it
looks like oh there's also electrical
wires too that's nice
there's like a couple different ones
the water pipes are thicker the
electrical ones are smaller all right
that just runs down the length
of the building there
and then these turn these also turn too
but they're held up by these little thin
ones every so often
these guys
so we can take this
um
maybe grab like this one here
and I know this is like technically what
it's not held up by but we're gonna see
if we can cheat it
[Music]
foreign
we could have
[Music]
a cylinder
[Music]
that just goes to the ceiling
up and out of view
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
oh come on now
and I'm gonna even give it the same
material even though it's probably not
going to look entirely right but
you're not gonna be able to tell
foreign
[Music]
I should be able to just duplicate this
now across the board
foreign
yo thank you for that Super Chat
I appreciate it I'm gonna need that uh
that motivation
because we are in the Weeds now we are
doing the details that are gonna pay off
here
I appreciate you very very much
thank you sir
all right so this will basically be
duplicated to the back I'm going to run
it lengthwise and then I'll probably run
some K some other cables
as well
um
boom okay
you know what I tell you that I'm gonna
undo all that
and group it from the top
and honestly it needs like little fire
spigot thingies I think
maybe I can just add those later
and I think that's what I'll do Ctrl G
Will Group
foreign
and then we'll select all of these
run them lengthwise
and then I'm going to try and go in and
add some like inconsistencies to them
and like some wobbliness
but let's rotate this 90
bring it up here
let's see how far we can
scoot this forward quite a ways quite a
ways
yeah okay
so basically right up into there
all right and I'll look at the reference
again to see like really where these are
coming from man there's a lot there's
like electrical up here
foreign
foreign
foreign
and we can run some
left and right as well
foreign
I'm going to duplicate or uh group all
this stuff
awesome and these could be like
who knows just other pipes
and we'll make sure it's as long as the
building
I think it'll just be easier that way
this one does not belong
that is right in the way of these lights
weird
sweet now let's see if I can
like
rotate this a little bit
get rid of snapping
foreign
this will give it some like really
subtle detail here
that I think will go
a long way
yeah it kind of bends down there this
one will be a little bit more obvious on
these sides here
foreign
[Music]
foreign
nice yeah
some inconsistency there looking good
[Music]
oh can I pull this off
I'd be a bit much but we will see
I'm excited for it
it kind of works yeah
janky pipes
another thing we could do we can
actually get some of these like
electrical conduits
little Outlets
um let's look for 3D assets here in
Bridge
it's a little wall thingy uh not these
ones
I mean we could probably just use this
one though
oh this is great the electrical box
let's definitely pull that
and let's grab this tiny electric box
too
foreign
ER that wow all right that okay so that
ain't a real Warehouse unless the pipes
have a leak with a puddle on the ground
let's
let's do that let's do that
let's go to decals
we'll go to leakage
uh we'll go to stamp
and is there not just a puddle
it's all like drips
and drops
hmm
I am going to grab this though
let's grab this one
let's also grab I want to have some like
grunginess coming down the side of
of these concrete pillars so I'm gonna
grab a few of these
let's see if we can't find like a puddle
um
Street mud tileable let's see okay
decals
um blood commercial concrete
oh we could also do some like
big old damaged concrete yeah this stuff
is great
grab some of that
we could grab some
what would really make this look nasty
some asphalt
crackage
this rebar stuff is great
we can grab this
damaged concrete
pothole let's try that
this is like probably what I'll do
at my end step
because I'll come through and like add
all of these
oh wow that grading is nice too leakage
oh shoot man like why is there not
puddles in here
hmm
now I have no idea what this says
oh it says no posters all right that's
probably not what I want it to say
for our thing
um
but some signage would be cool
Street
stain okay yes stain that is kind of
what I'm looking for uh that's more like
tar stuff
mud
Moss metal
leakage
why is it not under leakage debris
concrete commercial blood
vegetation
Tree Street Stone blood boss dang
I swore they had like
some really nice ones
coax thank you thank you
I appreciate that ah the Dizzy Viper
puddle pack that is truly the best the
best puddles
Brandon yo absolutely man you know it we
on it
ah this is like
the most unbroken amount of time I get
to work during the week so
it's actually really nice
[Music]
all right let's try this
puddle
ah it's all mud stuff I remember there's
a big one that we had for uh the the
stream I did with Steve begin
[Music]
but where the heck was that
was it imperfections
maybe it was imperfections I don't know
leakage grunge stains Stone
fingerprinting Frost damage
I don't know
y'all I do not know but we got some good
stuff we got some deep uh some some
decals
ah shoot I downloaded them but I didn't
export them
here we go
and we'll add
to the scene
yeah we could use blood and desaturate
it
I feel like it's not the same
uh Michael no not having a Quadro card
will not limit your capabilities in
unreal
I think you'll be surprised with what
you could do with a 30 70.
give it a shot my friend
[Music]
all right
let's see if we can't get some of these
decals popping off concrete damaged
foreign
like more on the bottom
[Music]
it says where stuff gets bumped
Samuel what's up
I download a lot of assets huh do I keep
them on my drives to delete them after
the project is done in my experience
they start to fill space fast yes they
do yes they do
um I have a like eight terabyte
[Music]
um SSD for all my VFX assets and from
time to time I will go through and I
will use a program called Winder stats
I'll type it into the chat
it's called windows
Direct
statistics or something I don't know
stands for something like that and um I
use that and it like visualizes all the
blocks of data on my computer and you
can see where the big chunks are coming
from they're cut they're color coded and
you can delete them that way so
I'll go through and I'll do that from
time to time for sure
all right I feel like this could be a
little brighter
um all right will it not let me brighten
it
huh it's weird
we can go into the diffuse texture
itself
and give it a brightness of like 1.5 or
something
that'd do anything
take the saturation down a bit
that's maybe a little bit more blended
into the scene
foreign
let's see what else we got concrete
damaged
it's more like a ground thing I feel
like
foreign
very subtle too
very very subtle
foreign
but if you put it maybe where the
reflection will be
picked up on it but it's not really
necessary I feel like
yeah it's not I don't think that's the
vibe
um
we have more damaged concrete
these rebar chunks they look nice
you gotta ask yourself why they're uh
why they're here what what would do this
kind of damage
and also why is it
duplicated over to this to this other
one
um
I'll leave it there for now just to know
that it's in place leakage all right so
I want to do
see we got some water pipes up here
maybe the water ran
how would this work
hmm
yeah it looks like it goes from top to
bottom and it actually doesn't
just kind of like taper off
foreign
way too much
goodness way way too much
foreign
you can get it in there subtle like that
but
I think it adds to be honest
you know maybe a little bit but
tough to say I'll leave it on there
again for now since we placed it
foreign
[Music]
how do you submit your render well
you click the submission Link in the
description below
or you go to the Discord server and you
submit through that Google form they're
both the same
for those of you who don't know
we have a
a way to submit your renders now we are
halfway through the challenge
and
if you are done with your render you can
submit the reason that I do this the
reason that we have the submission link
halfway through the challenge is so that
you don't feel the pressure to submit on
day one
it's way better if y'all take as much
time
as possible to make your heart as good
as possible because then it just brings
up the overall average quality of the
renders higher and higher
um that's why we released the submission
link halfway through these challenges so
it is live as of today like I said it's
in the description or also on the
Discord server I'll be making an
announcement a second announcement on
the Discord server with that link but it
is in the get started uh Channel
on Discord so you can check that out you
can only submit once all right so read
it very carefully please still work on
your art make it as good as you can
um obviously I still have a ways to go
here
and um yeah you can only submit it one
time so please make sure whatever you do
submit is that will be the version in
the montages all right
um so you can't be like oh but I
forgot to add a character no it's done
so please make sure your art is final
before
you turn it in
let's get back to the art I'll probably
do
just another I don't know 15 minutes or
so and then maybe hang out with y'all
for some q a and then I'm gonna get some
food
let's get back to it
Eric can you submit an mov it is in the
uh all that stuff all the technical
details are in
the rules
it's also on the submission page so the
answer is no we're talking MP4s
um there's a lot of renders that didn't
make it in last time to the montages
because the Codex were all weird
so we want to make sure that it's not a
codec issue that's why we're having
everyone do MP4s it worked really well
for the last Challenge and uh we're
doing it same deal for this challenge
maybe let's get a couple more water
pipes going
across the top
oh and that conduit
um
I want to get that as well
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
and let's get another one running down
here
like a little light switch situation
ah 3D sets
oh I didn't transfer them over that's
right
is to yes please
boom
all right
we got two of these we can figure out
which one we want to use
you also have to figure how big a human
is because
you know you walk up to this and you're
like okay I gotta work on this so it's
probably going to be
closer to this level
same for this one
probably be
around here
foreign
let's just get rid of this
nasty
foreign
and I want to run an electrical cable
to these all right so I'm going to grab
let's grab this
and we'll scooch it
see
move it right up to here
and it's going to run down
run down this thing
sweet all right
[Music]
foreign
foreign
thank you
oh windbrush what's up son
yo
so
when Bush and I
I believe if things are still going
according to plan last I heard
are going to be in Chicago for half res
on the
what is it 8th 9th and 10th or it's like
Friday is that Friday I think it's the
ninth
September 9th
um so come on out if y'all are in
Chicago or in the area me and Winbush
will be there we'll be speaking
um
what up son good to see you man
heck yeah
so let me get this pipe in place and
I'll show you what I've been up to here
but basically
we've been working on this like uh
Warehouse industrial scene
and working on the roof
trying to get everything looking nice
or let's say the roof I mean the ceiling
I always mean the ceiling
and just building it out yeah so we got
this angle is going to Dolly into this
close-up where
we're gonna
have a sweet little array here all these
little TVs are gonna display all the
different environments of the top 100
challenge
that's gonna be sweet
built out all these little screens
in c4d
brought him in here trying to figure out
what to do for the back background but
right now I've just been working on the
ceiling
and trying to figure out where all these
wires are going to go to
heck yeah eighth and 9th in Chicago me
and wind Bush be there y'all I'll be
there if you're in the Chicago area come
down say hello
it's gonna be awesome
all right let's try and get this like
a little bit more on to this thing
foreign
and this will be the one
that turns
there we go
same deal over here
foreign
if we can I might make these actually a
little skinnier
and then try and color them actually
the color of
this concrete and what I might do ah
maybe I'll just take oh maybe I'll take
this
if you do
was it control B yeah control B for
browse I'll just give the pipe this
electrical box material
and see if that
not the best
what we can do is go to materials
we will duplicate this material instance
and let's apply this here
and let's give it more of a
color of this concrete
can I eye drop yes I can
there we go
something like that
probably how they would do it
have it blend in just a little bit more
what
oh that's why
sweet
they probably paint this one up here too
try and just blend it in as much as
possible
I'm not gonna do all of them I'll just
see what this one looks like
oh
goodness
foreign
starting to look good
feeling pretty happy about this let's uh
move this down a little bit
and I'm selecting an object and hitting
F to snap to it
and that allows me to navigate a little
faster
and I could probably take that and and
flip it around
to get
a different iteration of it
there we go
starting to look pretty nice
oh
I can't forget I gotta get that
post-process material in
a little bit of
camera
lens distortion
feels a long way
it's getting there it is getting there
no doubt
um
well y'all
I
think
that is looking pretty nice
um I will be here with you all for the
next 10 minutes or so 5 or 10.
answer any questions you have
um that was great that was really great
I'm very happy with how this turned out
I can't wait to keep going at this going
at this environment and there's
definitely no way I'm gonna be able to
make a second environment because this
environment has
I could really make a lot out of this
and I'm so happy that I chose this idea
because it was something
a bit more bite size for me
um something that I think I can just
keep fleshing out pretty quickly
and something that I can actually
accomplish in the timeline
that I have here because I gotta finish
with you guys this time I'm gonna submit
with y'all uh on the deadline of what
August 28th 11 59 PM PST
as soon as it hits uh Monday morning it
is over because
Monday I'm going I'm starting the the
process digging through all the renders
finding the top 100 and that next
weekend we're gonna be breaking them
down with the guest judges so
we have two more streams next week and
the week after
I hope to be pretty close with my
character stuff by the next time we
stream
and then after that stream I hope to
have all the details done and actually
have renders out and in DaVinci
by the very last
stream and I'm we'll probably do some
sound design with y'all I'll probably do
some uh compositing some atmosphere work
some color correction tweaking all that
good stuff I will probably do on that
very last stream with y'all
uh visual thank you hey thanks for the
for the uh for the compliments man yeah
I think it's looking nice I'm excited to
keep working at it keep flushing it out
keep adding detail I'm really happy with
that ceiling
oh I want to do
shoot
oh man
okay
Maybe
I'm gonna try this
maybe I'm gonna try this right now I'm
just curious I'm gonna try this right
now
okay
so in
c4d
I want to have like uh this ceiling
actually sagged down a little bit like
it's made of uh some industrial foil
that is sagged over time
so
what I'm gonna do here
is make a plane I'm gonna do this with a
cloth Sim
I'm gonna make a plane
I'm gonna make a character
let's just bring it up you know
replicate our roof t for scale
scale it up
something like that something like this
okay I'm gonna have to refine this but I
really want to try this and let's go to
1 000 segments but actually no a million
seconds
let's not do that
let's start with a hundred by a hundred
okay
and
what I'm going to do is essentially
imagine that we have all these pillars
right running through all this
so I'm going to go through make this
editable grab my points hit zero for our
rectangular selection tool
and go through and just kind of pin
every four little bits like this
um in fact
make it easy on myself let's scale it up
to match the grid
and I'll just do the first four of every
major
line here
and we can duplicate this
in unreal
and then I need another four
unless I just
how I do this
set selection let's make uh
go to select
set selection should be in here
somewhere where are you set vertex
convert store invert
store selection is that what it's called
now
I guess so
I'll delete
this bit
boom there we go
now
we have all that selected right
I'm going to right click go to
simulation tags give it a cloth tag
let's go to the dresser and we want to
lock these points all right so I'm going
to set these fixed points
so those are locked right those points
are locked and if we hit
simulate
let me save this first hold on
for the
saggy
bling
yes
can we hit play actually I'm hitting G
I learned this from
uh Nick
Campbell Campbell Campbell over at
Gracie go gorilla you have framed
forward by one just to see what you get
and if you can do that enough times
okay now we know it's not working so
what is wrong with this
why is
it not
simulating
there we go there we go there we go
so you see how it sags now
that's perfect
we can go a step further and like
make it a little stretchy or something
we're going to take bendiness
stretchiness I don't know what if we
take stretchiness to five
and also
boom that looks to be our lowest point
frame
11. yeah frame 11 is our lowest point
which is great
take that and
I'll go back to dresser and I'm going to
set the initial State set it delete the
text it didn't work
try again
frame 11. if I just let's see if I set
the initial state
go back to frame zero right click this
and
connect objects or current state to
object
hmm
okay how do I bake this in how do I bake
this in
foreign
there we go
boom
right there
I'll take this
we'll save this as an fbx
okay
ceiling
back into unreal
all right and we're going to take
just bring that in uh
uh I'm brain dead at the four hour mark
y'all
mesh props
saggy ceiling
we want to import it uh combine meshes
yes yes all good
get that thumbnail edit mode going
bam all right bring it out
and our normals are jacked
can I how do I I don't know how to
invert normals here if I double click
this
little import method normal generation
cute way to normals
uh
uh UVs
don't know how to flip normals here so
I will do it here instead
you are flip normals
let's do it again export
fbx
you should be able to just right click
uh re-import
foreign
there we go yeah let's move around
let's see if we can't get this like
lined up
poking through nice okay
all right so it's pretty big
and just so I can see I'm gonna flip it
180.
and line up
scale it so that these are lined up
so I can probably uh
eyeball this up
and adjust it
a little bit later but
that is my plan
or the ceiling is to do it like that
we really like stretch it like this
let's have a sag
[Music]
foreign
yeah I'm about to line it up obviously
but
[Music]
and let's find this material
pop it on here
yikes there it goes
now it's kind of saggy
which is totally the vibe I'm going for
um
I'll have to figure yeah there's more to
figure out but that's my plan with that
do a little Sim and c4d sag the ceiling
so it's a bit more realistic
so I'm I'm amped I'm amped y'all
lots of good stuff to be done here
um
so
I'll hang without hey yeah
it just gets to that time y'all I will
hang out with y'all for the next five
minutes if you have any questions just
add me here in the live feed at Punisher
um if you are trying to get some kit
bash assets
I don't know how many codes are left but
there were there were 50 codes at the
top of the stream to get 40 off
um anything on kitbash3d.com there's a
link in the description below check it
out
um they are giving off giving away 50
this is difficult at the end of the
stream it's difficult they're giving
away discount codes at the end of every
God not at the end of every stream I'm
I'm butchering this y'all whoa
every stream this month kid bash3d is
giving away discount codes
um
there's only 50.
every time all right so I don't know how
many is left but 40 off
go check it out if you're trying to get
some kid bash stuff they are the best
the best it's gonna help you out with
your renders
um
wondrous will any judges guest judges be
returning to judge this challenge maybe
maybe not who knows
who knows
uh in time we will find out who's guest
judging
I would say the chances are probably
pretty high that there will be maybe one
returning guest judge
I don't know because I don't know yet
we're gonna figure that out
vormir thank you I appreciate that
what do you think about a character
creation challenge I think that's the
worst idea I've ever heard
characters are so hard
God I do not have a workflow for
characters
um I think it could be really cool
um in theory
having like uh a close-up character
each doing a thing
like each character is like
sitting center Shot
um in an environment that fits them and
it's a close-up of them I think that
could be pretty sweet
pretty pretty sweet but I think the
skill level goes way up to be honest
but not a bad idea
um
win custody
is asking
can you please tell me how long it might
take to move from c4d to Unreal great
question
um it took me
it took me like it depends on what
you're trying to do it really depends on
what you're trying to do
um but it took me quite a while because
the amount of tutorials out there they
weren't quite
up to Snuff they didn't offer me what I
was specifically looking for so it took
me about a year to like really
really get the hang of something to get
the hang of unreal
um to complete a project I made a music
video It's called um
it's actually a mouthful it's it's
called Sky too high
and Lin's Lin's heaven
virtual Plaza
this the song is called like something
Rush Hour
anyway it's an entire music video I did
in unreal four
and that was about a year and a half
into my struggling to learn Unreal
Engine and eventually
because of the project
was able to complete a project I was
able to learn so much
so these challenges here like the reason
I'm doing this
in unreal 5 this month is to learn as
much unreal 5 as possible
so you can give yourself really small
bite-sized little projects to tackle we
do weekly challenges when we're not
doing these big Community challenges on
my Discord server also linked below and
you can use
you know whatever program you want
um but they're bite size little small
weekly challenges and if you're trying
to learn a new program it's probably a
great way to to dive in and learn that
program
so it depends you know I put out a
number of tutorials in Unreal Engine for
people who are trying to switch over for
people who are trying to understand it
because I know I'm trying to understand
it William Foshay is a great resource
Winbush is a great resource so check
those people out if you're trying to
learn unreal
but uh let's see what else we got
I have something cool to that or to
share I guess go for it so in the last
stream
at the end of it we barely made it to 5
000 people that had not only gender
challenge but actually read the rules
and now we just hit 6 000 people so
that's pretty cool
heck yeah
ever had
Join one of these Community challenges
we have 6 000 people who have hopped on
Discord read the rules accepted the
challenge and are working away just
working away like like both of us here
well actually Soto are you are you doing
a submission
this uh this month or no no I I have
some kind stuff to finish and that has
priority of course but I think I might
do it just after the deadline for for
myself because this one I really wanted
to to get into it but
yeah I'm in time
um but yeah that's amazing 6 000 people
and we hit five 50 000 people on the
Discord server we recently as well so
that's great
um
let's see tinum update on my movie I can
tell you right now that writing
is harder than learning Unreal Engine
for me at least
so it is a struggle it's a constant
battle
waking up to solve advanced math
problems
is not
what I would call fun at this moment in
time
um
but
yeah it's tough I'm gonna have a whole
thing I'm gonna make a whole video on it
y'all writing a movie I'm gonna do a
whole thing on it
once I get through the process it's the
longest what a challenge
but we're gonna get there it's gonna be
awesome
um
blink says what software would you use
for cloth Sim unreal is proving a bit
difficult for class Sims I don't yeah I
mean I got c4d for my cloth stuff y'all
probably got blender for your cloth
stuff uh
yeah probably just do that
um
EDS who chooses the top 100 great
question
um so
myself and the moderators we go through
all of the
um the submissions
and I'll kind of give you a little
insight as to how this process works
we'll go through the thousands of
submissions and I'll do this in DaVinci
I will try and pull the top 125. so I'll
I'll raise them up on the next video
track and I'll pull the top 125 based
off of
first my eyeball is render quality
that's the first thing that my eyeball
will adjust to is like does it look
really good and if it looks really good
then it goes up
and
I will go through
all the videos
um and the mods again they hop in and
help out
I pull the top 125 with the moderators
um and then from there we kind of
Whittle it down like oh does it look
does it look good but like some
simulations are bad or like which which
ones are like the story just maybe it's
a little bit more generic and we'll try
and Whittle it down to the top 100. so
we'll go 125 to 100.
um
and then from there
I go through and I pull like the top
20.
and
um from that point I'll bring the top 20
to the guest judges
and then we'll Whittle that top 20 down
to the top five and then put them in
order of first to fifth
um
so that's generally how it works
the the judging process works
um and when we get down when we really
get down to that top 20 is when it gets
into like hours and hours and hours of
debate on like
yeah but this idea is cool but this
one's more unique and the simulation
here is a lot better but the lighting
here is a lot better and it's just like
hours of
because it's very serious it's a serious
thing like it's not something to be
taken lightly so
we definitely spend a good amount of
time on it
um I'm just looking at the at mentions
here
[Music]
um
what glasses am I wearing
these are from a website called Zenni
Optical they're very cheap
affordable glasses
um
they got a bunch of glasses yeah
um
[Music]
is it hard to think of new standard
animations for new challenges or do you
already know what the the new challenges
will be
um so that's from France uh
at this point we have like
a small pool of ideas for challenges
like this
um
and
it's always tough because
you know we're trying to mix what would
be fun for 3D artists but would also be
a blast to watch
or you know your grandma or something we
wanted to reach as many people as
possible
um so finding that balance is tough but
yeah we have we have a handful of ideas
for future challenges trying to do new
stuff really trying to like do different
things um things that
I'm basically just saying the same thing
in different ways yeah we try and find
new creative ways to do these challenges
so I think Dynamic machines might have
been the most unique and it'd be fun to
do something along those lines for the
next one
um but yeah we'll see we will have to
see
foreign
how is Da Vinci with effects
see I lost your question here we go
how how's Da Vinci with effects I've got
a little experience in the color
correction area but not editing or
effects so DaVinci actually does it all
which is amazing I have yet to use any
it's called Fusion that's their like VFX
situation
um and it's all like little tabs at the
bottom there's there's like six tabs
um
edit tab is the third tab I use that
basically most of the time I'll go into
the color tab a little bit to do my
color correction and then you have the
delivery tab which of course I use on
every project
there's the fusion tab in the middle
which is like after effects and I had
not figured it out yet
um Soto I know that you
have you used Fusion a little bit yeah I
use it all the time for compositing my
3D stuff it's it's based uh After
Effects is layer based like Photoshop
and then this is not based so maybe if
you've done like shaders or materials in
3D that kind of thing but for for video
so I think it's really good
yeah I'm trying to learn it
um it's very high on my list I'm just so
comfortable with After Effects
um but I mean yeah I switch over to
switch over to DaVinci
from Premiere just because it was so
much better and uh it's also free so
that's crazy
Matthew how am I gonna put the top 100
renders on my video screen display for
my render if I submit at the same time
as you guys
I'll just do it after
um let's see
Dawson can you confirm that retargeting
the animation was a key part of the
challenge part of this challenge
um yeah
I you know you need to put your own
character put a custom character onto
the mocap data there has to be a
character on on the vocab data
doing the moves absolutely
how long did it take to create all the
files for this month's challenge a long
time
a very long time
a lot of work went into capturing the
mocap data to cleaning up the mocap data
to figure out the challenge to writing
the rules to writing the announcement
video all that good stuff so
yeah there's a lot that goes into it a
whole lot that goes into it
um
you know from
setting up I'd probably say a month
month and a half maybe
let's see any others and I'll bounce
here I'm getting getting a little hungry
Ah that's a good question mate
maybe that's how you pronounce him
what's your advice on solidifying an
idea so that you can stick to it
to the very end of the project and not
get tempted by new ones popping out
throughout so yeah it's very easy to get
distracted and get and to move on to the
next thing move on to the next thing and
never finish what you're
what you've set out to do originally and
I think that
that we all struggle with I certainly
struggle with it as well
um
staying focused is very very important I
think
being on our phones being on social
media constantly having a phone in your
pocket pulling it out like I'm we we are
all
tempted by this and we all
fall short
um but
it doesn't help with our Focus that's
for sure it does not help with our Focus
so
you know I try and set timers like work
for an hour straight work for two hours
straight and stay focused on what you're
trying to do
um and it's difficult when like you're
you're just starting out and
you may not have the the skills or the
ability to just like push through and
keep um
the art that you put out
you're not getting excited by the art
that you're putting out by the work that
you're putting out so it's tough to give
up and move on to the next thing
um so I would just say stick with it I
don't know like really what else to say
besides uh stick with it take on little
bite size projects if you take on too
much then
you know it's
you're gonna get caught up and you might
get overwhelmed with what you're doing
so
bite-sized projects take on bite-sized
little projects at first things that you
can accomplish that's just a little bit
outside of your comfort zone
that's what I would do that's what I
would do for sure
um
let's see one more and we will move on
[Music]
foreign
not really question more of just like a
comment but
I'll shout it out he says you're not
only learning unreal from scratch for
this challenge but it's your first ever
3D render challenge you have no
experience and although it's really hard
I'm enjoying it immensely and that is so
good to hear so good to hear
um I'm glad that you're staying inspired
and that you're moving forward
and I'm glad that you're determined to
finish this thing
like yeah y'all thank you thank you so
much for hopping in with me for learning
with me for doing this challenge with me
and uh
I will see y'all next week I'll be on
the Discord server in the meantime uh
Monday if you guys want to stop by we'll
be on Monday doing a little town hall
meeting talking about everyone's renders
everyone's Works in progress answering
questions getting to know the community
a little bit more so come join us
and uh I will see y'all
next week how we going peace
[Music]
[Music]